- - Ça devrait ouvrir en 2025 53
- Il y a de nos géants,
de nos héros qui méritent
dans un musée avec tout
nos héros. Puis, pour moi,
Jean-Paul Riopelle fait partie
de ces géants.
- Et les géants tre
François Legault a annoncé la
création de l'Espace Riopelle.
Le nouveau pavillon du Musée
national des beaux-arts
du Québec sera entière
Jean-Paul Riopelle.
- En 1967, nous avons organiséné
la première grande rétrospective
de l'artiste à être présentée
au Québec. Depuis, nous lues
publications et expositions.
- Un don historires
d'une valeur de 100 millions $
de la Fondation Jean-Paul
Riopelle bonifie
JEAN-LUC MURRAY, directeur
du MNBAQ
- C'est sûr qu'on lui dédit déjà
un espace qui est tout petit,
à pon la plus
importante au Québec :
447 oeuvres qui uvres qui uvresr
de 68 oeuvres majeures,
souvent des grands formats.
- Afin de mettre en valeur
l'apport majeur de Jean-Paul
nouveau lieu était nécessaire.
L'Espae sera situé
dans le pavillon central du
Musée, avec vue sur les Plaines
- On a créé un plan
coule. Le pavillon est désuet.
pour l'été 2023, à temps
pour le 100e anniversaire
- On a créé un plan
d'implantation on a déjà tout ce
Des réserves etc.. on retire la
central et la verrière
besoin d'énormément
d'investissement parce que le
- Le début des travaux est prévu
centième anniversaire